>> Sean: HE'S BACK.
THREE YEARS AGO ABOUT THIS TIME
OF YEAR "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR, HE LAUNCHED
THE BOOK NUMBER ONE
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLER
"CLINTON CATCH."
HE'S OUT WITH A NEW BOOK
ENTITLED "SECRET EMPIRES, HOW
THE AMERICAN POLITICAL CLASS HAS
CORRUPTION.
LET ME JUST TOLD HIS AUDIENCE
BECAUSE I READ THE BOOK AND YOU
SAW I HAD THEM HIGHLIGHTED
TODAY.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO GET TO THE
WHOLE THING TODAY.
I WANT TO GIVE A BROADER
OVERVIEW AND DO WHAT WE DID LAST
TIME.
WE WILL BREAK IT ON ONE BY ONE.
YOU WERE THE FIRST GUY TO BREAK
URANIUM ONE.
TALK ABOUT PROFIT THROUGH PROXY.
YOU TALK ABOUT FIGHTING, YOU
TALK ABOUT CARRIE.
WE TALK ABOUT OBAMA.
TALK ABOUT REPUBLICANS.
MITCH McCONNELL.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS IS THE NEW CORRUPTION AND
THIS IS NOT THE CORRUPTION OF
$90,000 IN YOUR FREEZER.
THIS IS A MAJOR AMOUNTS OF MONEY
THIS IS A MAJOR AMOUNTS OF MONE
MONEY.
>> Sean: BILLIONS.
>> BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN SOME
OCCASIONS AND INVOLVES FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS WANT TO INFLUENCE
OUR READERS AND THE WAY TO GET
AROUND DISCLOSURES, THE WAY TO
GET ON THE LAW IS THEY DON'T GET
THE MONEY TO THE POLITICIANS.
THEY DON'T REALLY GIVE IT TO
THEIR SPOUSE.
THEY GIVE IT TO A SIBLING AND
THAT'S A WAY THAT IT AVOIDS
DETECTION.
THE AMOUNTS OF MONEY ARE
MASSIVE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE ARE THREE
MAJOR DEALS INVOLVING THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND FAMILY
MEMBERS, CLOSE AIDES OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE JOHN KERRY
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT --
>> Sean: HIS ADOPTED SON.
>> JOE BIDEN'S SON.
BASICALLY WHAT HAPPENED IS IN
2013 JOE BIDEN FLIES TO TRY NOT
TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT VERY
SENSITIVE ISSUES, THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA, TALK ABOUT TRADE
ISSUES, ECONOMIC ISSUES.
HUNTER BIDEN, HIS SON IS WITH
THEM ON AIR FORCE TWO.
IT'S FINE, THAT'S GREAT.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, TEN DAYS
AFTER THEY COME BACK, AFTER
POSITION TOWARDS THE CHINESE,
HUNTER BIDEN INCORPORATED, WHAT
BECOMES A 15 BILLION WITH A B
DOLLARS --
>> Sean: HE TAKES IT TO CHINA.
HE WAS BEING SOFT ON CHINA.
TEN DAYS LATER HIS SON GOT A
WHAT?
>> $1.5 BILLION PRIVATE EQUITY
DEAL.
THAT'S THE FIRST OF THREE.
>> Sean: 1.5 BILLION WITH A B.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S THE FIRST OF THREE DEALS.
THERE'S ANOTHER DEAL.
THIS IS ONE THAT INVOLVES
CARRIE'S FAMILY, ONE OF HIS
AIDES AND HUNTER BIDEN.
TECHNOLOGY PARTNERS, AND
OFFSHORE FUND.
CHINESE GOVERNMENT PUTS
$38 MILLION INTO THAT.
HER DEAL, ROSEMONT REALTY.
AGAIN INVOLVING THESE THREE SAME
INDIVIDUALS.
IF A CHINESE GOVERNMENT BUYS
THIS REAL ESTATE COMPANY, PUTS
IN $3 BILLION.
>> Sean: HOW MANY BILLIONS
BETWEEN THESE THREE ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT?
>> YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT IF YOU
ACCUMULATE ALL OF THEM, YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MULTIPLE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, AT LEAST A COUPLE OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, AND HERE'S
THE PROBLEM.
NONE OF THIS WAS DISCLOSED.
WE HAVE PICTURES OF IT, THE
DISCLOSED BECAUSE FEDERAL LAW
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES --
>> Sean: IT'S A DOORWAY.